summer is the voice of our generation
let me tell you why it was introduced to
most of us as Freddy Brooks on the
iconic 90s TV show a different world how
can I be okay Kimberly when mercury is
in retrograde
this means a very weird time
astrologically Freddy was known for
curly red hair lanús humor and
unapologetic activism she was a type of
know you can definitely expect to be
front and center at a woman pre began
joining voiceovers when she was just 11
years old ego Inspector Gadget was an
amazing experience it was my first
cartoon I got to look at my dad
it changed my life first signature raspy
voice has conquered the animation world
and has allowed her to bring so many
diverse characters to life green one
said her voice sounds like she dragged
her vocal cords done a dirt road and
then douse it in Jack Daniels and
methylated cool if he didn't take nobody
[Music]
remains to be one of the few successful
black actors and voice animation today
so a lot of I believe success animations
a really great imagination and thanks to
the road she paved she's inspired other
black actresses to take on voice acting
baby crazy that's why I dumped her yes
you always have to end up like this
right use a beach there's some very fine
young black female actresses coming up
in video in an industry where so many
black actors are overlooked and
typecasted voice acting allows black
actors to breathing life into so many
unique characters it gives the Mitanni
to navigate the stories of these diverse
creations although we have seen more
black actors and voice acting roles for
the past two years there's still so much
work to do I'll go in declare princess
and as you know I also like nobody's
doing princess I sound like the evil
breathe of shitty sister for the white
girl's best friend or whatever
your thanks to Chris on legacy we have
seen an array of unapologetic black
girls rise up and embrace themselves
from the hair to the clothes to taking
ownership of their own narratives free
has made such a profound impact on the
lives of black girls everywhere for
every character you have brought to life
with your voice and every black girl you
have empowered across the world Cree
summer we solution